the mass effect legendary trailer goes  through a ton of shots  really quickly so i've gone ahead and  slowed things down and captured a  ton of screenshots and then went and  captured as many of those scenes as  possible  in the original games so we can compare  them  but before we get to that i want to  thank you for watching this video  i love making stuff around mass effect  and if you haven't already subbed  consider hitting that button it helps us  a lot  alright enjoy  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you